you don't want yeah I got one this is my
last figure I of course I wanted to fill
this channel with some degeneracy just
you vazh I think I know what you just
the question is how much was I willing
to spend on it are you kidding me
yes reason really yeah yes yes oh my god
do you want to know how much I spend I
think I don't think I walked past and I
think I remember it being way over my
budget how much this was $170 when I saw
I was like I gotta get this cuz you know
you know that mean when it's just like
how to help me budget this correctly
when I was going through the sheet I was
like crossing off figures and she was
like just get rid of the [ __ ]
highschool DxD rid of the high school I
walked past this figuring in my video
and I was like I would get this okay if
it wasn't a hundred and seventy dollars
because I didn't want to go overboard
but the moment I saw and I'm like one of
these paths that feel when I realize
that I don't have the most expensive
figure yeah